so throughout the day we've been hearing
of all sorts of challenges that we face
when considering the future of food and
the challenges are going to require
creativity and we thought that there's
no better assemblage of people to talk
about creativity than a group of six
visiting Nobel laureates so I'd like to
start by asking them about what they
think is the best condition for
fostering creativity let's start at the
end of the row Steve well I think it's
the immediate environment that we find
ourselves in immediate environment means
colleagues but there's also another
thing and that is there's also it's
about food but I'm gonna talk about
another hunger that people are driven
because they really want to understand
how the world works there is another
thing and they really want to do some
good in the world and especially in my
career as I got older I began to that
began to dictate what I was getting
interested in and as after coming out of
government I'm starting a new lab again
and that is also influenced which what
direction I'm going hmm
and do you feel conditions for
creativity these days are improving
generally you it's mixed I think what
you need is you have to have an
environment that nurtures young people
that says if you do want to I'll stick
to science saying going to science and
do good things that it there's a
possibility that you can get a job not
to get rich but to but be able to do the
things you want to do whether it's in
academia or an industry or someplace
like that
I think there's it's a mixed bag I think
like a lot of the younger people don't
feel quite as encouraged as I did when I
was growing up in the United States but
I grew up in a split
kara where you know they wanted to
really train the new generation of
scientists you know but why shouldn't
that be challenges like that now there
should be oh I mean if you consider that
this is what we have to do what we're
facing in terms of climate change in
terms of energy sustainability food the
whole thing this is a calling that's
huge and a huge scientific challenge and
and rather than going to arms or being
financed by a cold war this is something
that should get societal interests it
should get people that said yes this is
something that society had writ large it
can rise up to and it is a huge
challenge this I'm coming I'm going
randomly among you what do you think I
love what Patti Smith said when she
invoked silence because to me that's
where that's where the wellspring of
creativity really really comes and and I
think it's when you you look at the
wonder of nature I I'm president of the
Salk Institute and one of the young
scientists said to me when I walk across
the courtyard of the Salk Institute and
I look at the Stars I think anything is
possible and she just said this to me
and I just thought no I'm that's what I
love is being in a place where people
have that sort of inspiration from what
they do but I think that's where we have
to let silence sort of happen so we can
let that creativity rise up I'm reminded
of these jellyfish images which is like
the thoughts of their creativity coming
up so I think we have to make space for
silence and I think that's where
creativity will grow I guess it's harder
and harder to find space for silence
these noise-canceling headphones let's
use technology
Kristiana what do you think much - my
thoughts - I mean silence is perhaps not
the exact right word I think if you have
money
- she runs out from all these influences
and when you ask the question what what
about what changed in the past 20-30
years we are so overwhelmed with
information and we can get information
so quickly and when I think we easily
fall into this trap to just look into
the internet constantly and get
distracted from our own thoughts and I
think if you want to be creative you
must concentrate focus on something you
must shield yourself from from our
outside influences and and poke on these
questions why and how when you when they
raise your interest and and yeah and I
think this is really something we have
to keep in mind that if you want to be
creative not just productive and we want
to be original
not just productive we have to
concentrate and and and be a little
isolated from from interchanging
constantly with other with other people
and other influences it's it's somewhat
contra to the kind of current thinking
that people so frequently say that the
information of information age makes
everything possible it's networking an
idea that you'd constantly have to be in
contact with other people is just not I
don't think it's the best way when you
need to be connected of course but you
also have to find your own way and not
be constantly asked what are the others
doing and what's coming up there what's
coming up there I think it's really
important
as in my case I tend to be rather
skeptical and so if people tell me or
you shouldn't do this I always think
maybe there's something really good to
do there but if they say I'll do this I
think that's going to be mundane and so
I kind of like to do other things I have
an inherent curiosity about many things
nature included and I would agree
totally you need to be inside yourself
from time to time so that you can really
look and see is there something
interesting going on that you would like
to know how it works my own work at the
moment is of bacteria and there is
something very interesting going on in
bacteria and we understand a little bit
of it but there's a big swath of it that
we really don't understand at the moment
and so for me that's what gets me up in
the morning it's what stops me from
sleeping at night and it's what drives
my wife crazy because I'm always trying
to find out about this stuff
Angus okay well I think I agree with
everything that's been said not enough
to give up my chances
it's I want to say something too I mean
you've got six attested or how many of
us yeah six attested creators here so if
you want to know more about creativity
maybe you should ask the people who were
not creative and why they were not if
you want more creativity then you know
you've got to get for those people it's
clearly true that you need to sink into
yourself so that part of it I think we'd
probably all attest to you need lonely
time somewhere deep in someplace where
you're struggling to get out of but one
thing that I'm not sure is widely
appreciated is just how important the
social incentives are for creating
creativity so I think throughout history
there's a sort of micro view of someone
sitting there waiting for creativity to
fall on their head
but if you study it in a more macro
historical perspective there's usually
something going on in the environment
which is pressurizing people to solve
that problem this is not mechanical at
all in the sense that there are many
presses pressing social problems that
don't get solved that way but if you
think of Kemal era for instance the 19th
century cholera wave was very important
in producing the germ theory of disease
and that you could make a good argument
that if I had not been the cholera
epidemics the germ theory would have
been much postponed or much lower
there's a very respectable set of
theories that says the Industrial
Revolution in Britain was caused by high
wages in Britain and Britain had sort of
won the age of empire and so British
working people were so expensive that
people looked for substitutes and it was
the looking for substitutes that spurred
the creativity that generated the
Industrial Revolution so I tell stories
of course the war on cancer has not been
nearly so successful and producing great
innovations that there are great
creativity in cancer these things that
can't be tailored to order it's not a
process like that but it's really a
mistake to think about a lonely
individual you know just something
falling on there add and you get this
revelation and it also suggests that
lots more people who were not creative
could have been creative had they been
in the environment you know I was lucky
enough to be around where there was a
bunch of stuff going on that I could
retreat with me to my dark hole and work
on and come up with something new but if
those things had not been there it
wouldn't have been possible for me to do
that Steve talks about being a Sputnik
scientist so I mean that's another very
good example of how is social pressure
said we you know we've got to do
something about this so they poured
money into education and produce the
physicists that they needed you know
sometimes it works so and that mention
of the greatest power of the individual
plays exactly into Muhammad Yunus is you
know he's been making so well I look at
it
they process like all Impossibles
without remotely become possible now we
have a bigger chance because Impossibles
get possible faster than it did before
so I tell the young people particularly
now figure it out make a list of all the
Impossibles that you see because soon
that list will be shorter and shorter
you'll miss out your chance to translate
one of those Impossibles into possible
so before you exhaust your chance you
want to get in and do it this is one way
to activate activate the process if you
have endless power of creative power
yourself but if you first of all we
become aware of that power and then when
you become aware of the creative power
that you have then you ask yourself what
are you going to use it for having power
is meaningless if you're not using it so
this is another attraction that how to
make the use of the creative power and I
take the example of science fiction I
set ups I love science fiction because
it's all about wild imagination all
kinds of thing is possible in science
fiction that's why we get glued into
science fiction you want to watch it
what's happening and we know absolutely
very well these are all fairy tales it
doesn't exist probably it will never
exist but we like that let the power of
imagination is comes up there and I say
and the science sorry technology follows
the science fiction and make it happen
and many of the things we see today in
everybody's position are things which
were in science fiction at one time now
became real I said I wish somebody had a
series like science fiction is social
fiction make wild ideas about the
society how this can be the while that
it gets more challenging and more
creative it becomes because that's where
now in fascination comes and maybe we
should get together make it happen
I like how you said the phrase
fairytales because people would
presumably mostly dismiss it as childish
but maybe that's where every way we
should be thinking about what we should
be aspiring for how important is
creativity how much of a role did it
play in your own I would say the core of
human being without creativity human
being just like another species which is
not much to contribute human being takes
challenges as imagination and that
imagination triggers all the creative
power inside of them to make it happen
human being I don't think they accept
Impossibles they get always get kind of
challenged by seeing something
impossible I always say why can't we do
it possible which ways do we do that
so we keep on pushing the door pushing
the frontier making it happen that's why
things start happening there is you're
nodding do you want to say yes I think
you were saying does that play a role
and but yeah you know we we saw
something happening with DNA that
shouldn't have been happening you know
the textbook said shouldn't be happening
so I had to imagine there was something
and I imagined an enzyme right and you
knows it said well this thing that
doesn't exist maybe it exists and so I
think that was a creativity aspect of it
who made having it what's there before
then you had there was hard work going
in and actually finding it but I think
you had to first imagine the possibility
of something that nobody ever said
should be going on so that's very
important thank you I think creativity
in innocence is combining facts which no
one else had combined before so finding
connections between things which are
everybody can see but to get the
connections in your brain means that you
have you let these different things
enter your brain and then play around
and we all know this that you think
about something very hard and you can't
find a solution and next morning you
wake up and all of a sudden you know the
solution and this is in the mind somehow
uses the info the information input and
and and somehow it is working in the
brain in your unconsciousness and I
think but it's very important as a basic
basis for that is to have the right
surrounding which gives you this input
which you can use so I think when
when young people ask me where they
should go what they should study also I
always say go to a good place where
there are smart people who pop up ideas
and information which is interesting and
not just to places where yeah the babies
I mean very it's just not interesting
and interesting means something special
and you get several interesting aspects
and then you combine them in your head
and then you create something new I
think that's that's the sense thank you
we're getting very close to time we're
getting also very close to the end of
the year and in some ways it's been a
pretty tough year
so shall we end with some something
positive Steve give us a positive
thought hope to make it for the next
four years no seriously I think since
we're here celebrating you know Nobel
Prize science it is something where I
feel very deeply that it's not only fun
to do but it can really help in many
respects sometimes it helps decades
later in a very unintuitive ways and so
that just doing what really interests
you and knowing historically that the
payback might not be immediate may not
be ever but but it's it's that long view
that it will come back and
and enrich the world hmm and it's that
redefinition of the way payback of the
word payback yes not maybe not in my
lifetime but yes exactly okay thank you
all very much indeed
I just have two things to say very
quickly the first is that none of this
would be possible without all the
participants and the audience and all
the team who put it all together but
also the partners who pay for all this
and I would like just to name them
acadmica who's Carl Burnett a be the
city of Gothenburg iike Eriksson and
this is always the difficult one for me
I kinda have to slow down because the
pronunciation the region vestra Yertle
and
[Music]
and the other thing is just say thank
you and see you all in Gothenburg on the
9th of December in 2017 for the next
novo $8
[Applause]